well search crews in Northern California
have found six more bodies bringing the
death toll from the so called campfire
248 a new lawsuit blames the fire on a
major utility Pacific Gas and Electric
for allegedly failing to inspect and
properly maintain its power lines in a
statement PG P&G said a customer safety
is its highest priority and it's
focusing on helping first responders
Gudea vdl is at Paradise California
where a nurse barely escaped the flames
and then learned that her father is
missing midday a good morning well good
morning the camp fire has been burning
now for nearly a week and it's 35
percent contained so there is progress
being made
we spoke with 30 year-old Chardonnay
Talley who says she had just minutes to
escape a burny hospital with patients
she saved those patients by the way but
now she knows that her father is missing
she hasn't seen him since the blaze
ignited last week that was his garden
Chardonnay telly and her husband Ernesto
say they felt compelled to search
through the rubble of what was her
father's home hoping to find any sign of
life in the burned-out woods nearby this
is the escape route tally went through
as she fled the hospital where she
worked
transporting a critical care patient in
one ambulance as she followed another we
made it I don't know maybe a half a mile
before the ambulance in front of us
caught fire and everything around this
was on fire and we put the patients out
of the immanent so it's on fire and put
them in a garage and everything burn
around us
you called your husband what you say to
him on the phone
and said we're not gonna make it out of
this and I feel like my patients gonna
die to tell the kids that I love them
and to check on my dad in the moment
that you thought you weren't gonna make
it you were thinking of your dad what
does it mean to you obviously a very
dramatic scene with Chardonnay yesterday
right now authorities though they are
working on putting together an official
list of people who are missing right now
a lot of information is coming in and
out so they're trying to update that
list as soon as they cancel they can
actually focus on the people who are
really missing rather than the people
who just haven't been able to
communicate that they're okay maybe
they're at a shelter despite searching
for several hours yesterday guys
Chardonnay did not find her her father
out there on his property or any sort of
evidence of where he might be
Nora you really feel her pain and her
concern Maria thank you